I'll say this plainly I've said it
before taxation is theft it presumes
that the government has a higher claim
on our property than we do
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're very happy to be talking
with Judge Andrew Napolitano the host of
the great Fox Business show freedom
watch as well as the author of the new
book it is dangerous to be right when
your government is wrong Judge Andrew
Napolitano thanks for talking to a
pleasure to be here Nick it's nice to
have the opposite role of what you and I
normally have this time you're the
Inquisitor I am not sure which is more
terrified for me but I can go with here
you know a short history of some of the
books that you've been turning out over
the past few years include
constitutional chaos then you have
titles like - a nation of sheep or
rather a nation of sheep - dred Scott's
revenge - your current book it is
dangerous to be right when your
government is no I'll get the
constitution in exile oh now I know that
as well as dred Scott's revenge but I
mean I sense in the arc of your titles
more militancy do you feel that we're on
a downward path irrevocably are
irrevocably towards a loss of freedom
and liberty I think we're on a downward
path I don't think it's irrevocable and
I have to give full credit for the title
of this book - Voltaire who actually
suggested it to me one day of course
it's 250 years old and a famous phrase
from him it is dangerous to be right
when the government is wrong look in one
respect women have full rights and
african-americans have full rights it
shouldn't be something we are happy
about but when you consider the historic
treatment of African Americans and women
it's about time they have those rights
and as much as I love Jefferson they
didn't have them in that era in that
respect we are a broader more expansive
freer society but with respect to the
level of regulation by the government
the areas of human behavior utterly and
totally dominated by the federal
government much less a state government
the surveillance state the welfare state
the warfare state the regulatory state
the administrative state we are on a
downward spiral and we are losing
Liberty with every tick of the clock and
unless we get a game-changer in the
White House and the Congress or on the
courts the spiral will continue one of
the your chapters has to do with the
right to own property
yes you know if we go back to the kilo
decision which was what 2005 rate you
know that that was horrible Aquila
decision which basically the Supreme
Court said yeah a state jurisdiction or
a you know a state political body can
take whatever they want from a private
property owner immediately to turn it
over to another private property owner
as eminent domain abuse you know defined
but that also sparked a counter force
against eminent domain abuse so are we
fighting the good fight or you know in
these cases we are fighting the good
fight in fact just three days ago the
good people of the state of Mississippi
amended the state's constitution to
prohibit any state government in
Mississippi from doing what the supreme
court authorized in kilo and of course
the case the kilo case only got to the
Supreme Court because the state of
Connecticut did not have such a
prohibition but as much as I love the
fifth amendment which requires that if
the government wants life liberty or
property it has to engage in due process
which prohibits torture and compelled
testimony against oneself it is the
linchpin of big government here's why
Jefferson argued and I believe that the
only moral valid lawful exchange of
property is one that is truly voluntary
Hamilton wanted at the Constitutional
Convention the same powers that the king
did which is the power to take any
property and the king would decide
whether or not he owed you anything they
compromised with the fifth amendment
which is the government can take what it
wants but it's got to pay you a fair
value for it and the government has to
use it for a public use Jefferson warned
that the public use would be whatever
the government wanted its friends to
have and that's where we are and it's
because Jefferson's warnings were
disregarded that the government can now
take anything so I asked in the book do
we really own anything can the
government take that infamous leather
jacket that you're now wearing answer
yes it can I just know pays you the fair
market value is going to say it's really
not worth very much because it's yours
no it's worth of course I was going to
say it's even well I said it's like a
car judge as soon as I walk out of the
store with it at 50% so some
well let's say you also talk and I mean
you you have a long list basically of
all of the you know all of our basic
rights the right to speech there's no
question that with you know in any
number of ways the government at all
levels is constantly trying to restrain
and curtail our speech political
expression things like that by the same
token you know technologically it's
clear that we're able to express
ourselves more freely more effectively
than ever we saw this with you know
things like mccain feingold you know the
attempt to use campaign finance laws in
order to stop political speech
forget about what the Supreme Court said
in Citizens United I mean the fact is is
that people are now able to express
themselves more freely is that you buy
that and is that enough no I don't buy
it okay two FBI agents walk into a
library in Bridgeport Connecticut and
one of them has a self written search
warrant under his arm I know this sounds
like a joke two guys walk out bar one of
the duck under is our but it's true and
they serve a self written a search
warrant which under the Patriot Act they
author they wrote for themselves and
authorized themselves to the head
librarian saying we want to know what
books so-and-so is taking out and by the
way you can't tell anybody that we were
here the librarian is 86 years old the
FBI agents are in the early thirties she
says who the hell are you she hands the
search warrant to her 75 year old
assistant fast forward two years later
they're in court because they talked
about it the latest trend in in free
speech violations is compelled speech
there there's a sub rosa trend amongst
prosecutors now to prosecute people for
failing to report crimes that they have
witnessed and I will tell you under the
law you have no obligation to report
anything that you see except treason the
limit seven trees and prosecutions and
two hundred and thirty years the same
First Amendment which prohibits the
Congress from infringing free speech
prohibits it from compelling speech so
prosecuting someone for not speaking and
then prosecuting someone for speaking
truthfully I got a search warrant from
the FBI what should I do about it
our egregious violations of the First
Amendment you are you were talking about
we need to get people in the courts in
the White House in Congress I mean
is this something that is going to be
solved are these infringement sand
incursions on our rights is that really
going to be solved by politics or how to
because isn't politics the problem
politics is the problem Nick it's a good
question when when george w bush was
elected in 2000 put aside the manner of
his election i wrote about that i was
critical of the court and the
republicans took over the congress like
a lot of libertarians i rejoiced because
I thought after these years of Bill
Clinton will finally get small
government instead we got a government
that was less faithful to the
Constitution than any government since
Abraham Lincoln's years because there's
just a Republican version of big
government so when I say a game-changer
in the White House or the Congress of
the courts I'm talking about somebody
like Ron Paul someone who was utterly
totally and and without exception
faithful to the values of the primacy of
the individual the government must stay
within the confines of the Constitution
so for Ron Paul to return us to that
government would require half the
Congress agreeing with him and half the
Supreme Court agreeing with him do I
expect that to happen miraculously in
the next 13 months I don't but it could
and I mean you must take I think a lot
of people who believe in limited
government and libertarian ideals I mean
when you look at the popularity of Ron
Paul who those of us in the movement
have been following him for decades but
I mean over the past five years he's
emerged as you know one of the great
national leaders of the debate you know
in politics and I like to to think that
Ron Paul is Barry Goldwater and
somewhere out there in the next
generation is Ronald Reagan
there wasn't a Reagan Revolution yeah it
didn't happen the way we thought it
would happen after Ron Paul and
completely subvert everything that he
actually stood no I want somebody come
after Ron Paul and perfected we thought
Reagan would perfect it we now know he
didn't for a variety of reasons we could
talk about in another in another form
but Ron has succeeded in moving into the
mainstream debates over issues and
institutions
which are very serious like the Federal
Reserve right well years 20 years ago
the establishment didn't want to talk
about the Federal Reserve
now even Democrats is saying you know
what we need to know what's going on
there right and well because of Ron and
also the Pentagon I mean he has really I
mean not since you know basically not
since Eisenhower warned about a
military-industrial complex do we have a
guy who's actually you know putting that
on the agenda correct let's talk about
some of the dicey er issues or ones that
separate libertarians among themselves
in your book you talk about the right to
own your own body but then you're also
very pro-life your anti-abortion I am so
where does the right to own your own
body stop and where does the right to
the infant or the fetus or the potential
human life begin I believe and it is a
it is a question of science and it is a
question of faith that a fertilized egg
is a human being it is the byproduct of
copulation by two human beings I'm not
talking about some scientist in a petri
dish now and it has a full human genome
and I accept that as a as a definition
stated differently it has all the
chemical and biological makeup necessary
to become human with the with the to
become a person as we understand it now
that's a legal purse of with the
fertilized egg that has been implanted
in in the uterine wall is it not just
not just simply a fertilized that
correct okay
correct correct if we can't draw the
line there there is no intellectually
acceptable place to draw the line other
than the convenience of the mother so
when I say you have the right to own
your own body the fetus is not your body
people say it's easy for you to say that
because you're not a woman I am
obviously not a woman but I say it
because of my fidelity to some basic
libertarian virtues the primacy of the
individual the individual is greater
than the state the state cannot without
the the greatest violation of a moral
law authorize one human being to take
the life of another do you support the
prosecution of doctors and nurses and
medical personnel who
perform abortions the answer is yes
however we have not seen that because of
the bizarre frequency with which
abortion what about what about women who
you know who have abortions performed
and you don't let's say the men who
drive them there as well should they be
prosecuted anyone who kills an innocent
life whether it's george w bush or
somebody in a back alley should be
prosecuted for killing the innocent life
i'm not suggesting george w bush in this
context was right back to abortions i'm
talking about other other killings for
other goals that he stated where where
does this rank i mean because this seems
like it should be at the very pinnacle
of your it should but it's not yeah so
is just explain a little bit i mean if
if the government were in the streets
randomly killing people there would be
riots in the streets to stop it but
because we have sterilized this murder
authorized it legislated it blessed it
if you will lowercase b and blessed
there are no riots in the streets
because the victims cannot speak for
themselves because they are totally
dependent upon the perpetrator of the
crime because it happens in a sterile
environment there are there is not an
outcry yes there should be within the
kind of broad base i mean you have
thousands of people a year on your show
you talk to a lot of libertarian
audiences are your crowd favorite i mean
you are the rock star of Freedom Fest in
Las Vegas every year and other things
you weren't there this year
well but how many people agree with you
who call themselves libertarians you
guess and I I would say that about half
of our libertarian colleagues are
pro-life and about half are not well and
then you had mentioned that it's a for
you it's a matter of science and a faith
one of the chapters in your book which i
think is wonderful is you quote from the
the great play a man for all seasons
which is about thomas moore and you call
it when the devil turned round on you
which is a line of
how you know you need to understand the
state needs to be relatively powerless
because once it becomes powerful enough
to do what you want and it can turn on
you what's the role of faith you are
practicing Catholic a lot of
libertarians are seem hostile to
religion or indifferent to religion
what's the role of your religious
beliefs in your belief in individual
dignity and rights I am NOT just a
Catholic I have to characterize this
today because of what's been happening
to the Catholic Church in the past 50
years
I am a pre Vatican 2 Catholic I am a
traditionalist with a capital T I am an
Orthodox with a lowercase o
Roman Catholic I know you're laughing
because you and I've talked about the
story but it's also because I've Amla
mentally typing and shifting capital
right one can't say uppercase o because
something that they are not Roman then
your Easter yes everything I do or say
is filtered through my internal screen
of Catholicism I am thrilled beyond
compare at the number of libertarians
who carry rosary beads in their pockets
think of the message of Jesus the
individual is greater than the state I
am here to save individuals in spite of
the state this is a libertarian message
if ever there was one doesn't mean you
have to be Catholic doesn't mean even
have to believe in God if you believe as
I do that we were created in the image
and likeness of God then as God is
perfectly free we are perfectly free if
you believe that we are the the highest
result of some natural selection then
you also believe that that highest
result humanity has free will and
intellect to exercise that freewill
either origin biological or theological
gets you to the point of the primacy of
the individual over its artificial
organization based on a monopoly of
force which we call the government Jesus
is also remembered for saying render
unto Caesar what is Caesar's and render
to God that which is God's how do how do
you tell the difference I mean you talk
a lot in your books consistently and in
your show about natural law higher law
explain that for people who might not be
familiar with it and how does that help
you decide okay well Caesar has a
legitimate claim on this but not on this
the natural law teaches this is
Aristotle
this is Aquinas this is Thomas More this
is John Locke this is Thomas Jefferson
this is Clarence Thomas to some extent
Nino Scalia as well I mean them no
disrespect try calling them by their
first names argument is that our rights
come from our humanity that my right to
think as I wish and speak as I think and
publish as I speak to worship or not to
worship self-defense privacy my right to
be left alone are integral to my
existence I have them because of a human
being they don't come from the
government that's not an academic
argument because if these rights do come
from the government then the government
by ordinary legislation or executive
command can restrict those rights if
they come from my humanity then the
fifth amendment comes in the government
can only interfere with those rights
life liberty or property with due
process meaning show me what I did wrong
prove it to a neutral jury let me defend
myself and challenge you and give me the
right to appeal basing to but then also
it's not simply procedural due process
right it's substantive because your book
treads got revenge which is a
fascinating history of race and law in
America I mean you did you know you take
issue with the Dred Scott to see some
things are just plain wrong and to
suggest that one class of people can
enslave another class of people not
because of any culpability on the part
of the enslaved class but just by virtue
of their place of origin or the color of
their skin violates substantive due
process which basically means the law
has to be fair it has to be as Aquinas
would have said and did say a rule of
right reason for the common good not a
rule of convenience for the good of some
so where does taxation fit into that so
the the income tax as opposed to excise
taxes because the federal government
before we had personal income tax most
of their money came from tariffs and
excise taxes are those moral and income
tax immoral or are both
or you're home at night and someone
knocks on the door and you answer the
door and there's a guy with a gun and
the guy says give me your money I want
to give it away in your name was this
guy crazy call the police you find out
he's an IRS agent so that's what
taxation is it is the government
extracting money from you against your
will to give it away in your name
I'll say this plainly I've said it
before taxation is theft it presumes
that the government has a higher claim
on our property than we do when the
government imposed excise taxes that was
a user fee you want to use the
government sport the government owns the
water and owns the earth it shouldn't
but does you have to pay for that right
so before the War Between the States the
central government existed by user fees
it existed by selling government land
government still owns what 88% of Nevada
that's a lot of land and it also exists
existed by imposing burdens on the
state's financial burdens for the
services the central government
performed that's the way it was intended
to be after the 16th and 17th amendments
the Senate is no longer representative
of the states and the feds can take a
portion of your income tax the feds take
whatever they want if those two
amendments alone were to be repealed the
government would go back to the confines
of the Constitution almost overnight now
you know it's funny you you talked about
the war between the states as opposed to
the Civil War concept yeah i snarky well
I was going to ask now here clearly and
you mentioned Lincoln in a negative way
Lincoln in many ways is the worst
violator of the Constitution you know
just you know when you run through what
he did in order to process the Civil War
the Confederate States of America worse
still because they were fighting for the
right to maintain slavery right I
believe that they were fighting for a
right to secede from a central
government just as we seceded from Great
Britain they were also fighting for
slavery the worst abomination in the
history of the world but it is not the
job of the United States of America to
go around looking for monsters to slay
which is what
yeah so it put yourself back in 1860
would you have joined an Abraham Lincoln
brigade obviously name something
different at the time maybe a John Brown
Brigade to go in and help overthrow the
Confederate States of America I think
that slavery would have died a natural
death here as it did in Puerto Rico and
Brazil in Portugal and in Great Britain
and I think it was on the verge of doing
that at the time Lincoln decided to
start killing people in your book you
quote you know the I guess Thomas Paine
and then you said it's also it goes back
to Aquinas but that we have a positive
moral duty to disobey stupidity in the
same chapter you also talked about and
I'm quoting here wise folk wise folks
are buying guns and gold are you getting
militant are we going to see are you
going to be having Patty Hearst on your
show anytime soon a story ever ray but
what you know what what are you getting
out there and at what point does the
positive moral duty to disobey stupidity
and and to refuse to go along with laws
that are immoral well is that sanction
violence against the state there's a
potential for violence I'm certainly not
encouraging violence but Aquinas taught
us that you an unjust law is no law at
all and the sit-ins of the lunch
counters in the south and the 50s and
60s
these are courageous people and we're
using nonviolent means to resist and
reject an unjust law Jim Crow law the
Jim Crow laws compelled the lunch
counter owner to segregate by sex
whether the lunch counter runner wanted
to do it or not the evil was the law the
evil was not the person behind the lunch
counter the southern legislatures lacked
the political will to change that the
southern courts lacked the political and
the intellectual will to change it it
was only a non-violent refusal to obey
an unjust law that changed it that's
what I'm talking about bring it to today
we'll go back to our friends in the
library in Bridgeport the the end of
that story is a happy one by the way
because on the eve of the trial of the
by then 87 year old librarian and her 77
year old assistant a federal judge said
to the US attorneys
I'm about to declare the Patriot Act
unconstitutional you still want to go
after these two ladies for discussing
this warrant suddenly the case
disappeared lately another Subrosa trend
I'll tell you about federal agents
serving self-written search warrants on
say a commercial owns a computer store
wanting to know who bought a mobile
phone who bought a laptop they're not
complying with it they're taking it to a
lawyer and challenging it and what a
judge is doing in validating it is that
a technical violation of the Patriot Act
yes it is does it result in a greater
freedom yes it does is it an example of
violating an unjust law without
obstructing a governmental function and
without causing violence yes it is so
that's what I'm talking about on the end
at the end in terms of guns and gold
they are the only material things that
will save us talk about Occupy Wall
Street real briefly because they they
believe that they are protesting you
know in the name of a higher law of
righteousness where were they
where do you find them mistaken we we
sent some of our freedom Watch producers
down there to interact with them and we
were surprised at what we found and this
is a month ago now I know this is a
changing by the minute I believe it has
since been taken over the Democratic
Party and professional activists but
before that happened at least in the
crowds that we interviewed in lower
Manhattan in late September about a
third of the people we're wearing pins
are carrying flags that said don't tread
on me and of the demands of the crowd
and the fed and the wars and the IRS the
wall street car was going along with the
first two now they don't
Lefty's don't want to end the IRS they
want to use the IRS to steal more than
it already steals and the other day I
was speaking at a group and some of
these folks showed up I couldn't hear
what they were saying is they were
screaming so loud I said I may disagree
with what you say but I will defend to
the death your right to say the crowd
loved it and they loved it I welcome
this controversy I welcome this dispute
obviously I condemn the
Oshin that the government should use its
power to take from those who have and
give to those who have not but to the
extent that this causes a debate about
the fundamental role of government in
our lives it's a good one the issue in
New York is a bizarre one because it's
private property dedicated to the public
use by the force of law it's a bad law
you should be able to invite and exclude
whomever you want on your own private
property the city of New York does not
permit that because the city of New York
barely barely recognizes private
property rights well I want to thank
Judge Andrew Napolitano the host of
freedom watch on Fox Business Monday
through Friday it's a great show and
also the author now most recently of it
is dangerous to be right when your
government is wrong judge thanks very
much for talking to Reason thank you for
coming on my show once a week we love it
I appreciate that very much
for recent TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you